but I also got the intern for DJ Laz who
was on Power 99 Legend my channel
so my first internship was with Joe Rose
at 560 QAM and that was a sports Morning
Show and then I was able to get an
internship through constantly poking my
head in bothering classes that was when
he was doing mornings at Power 96. yes
so so I got an internship there and
works past my school internship and you
know just did the internship for free
whatever but I got incredible experience
and I really learned how to produce
shows from working with Laz because
sports and entertainment crossovers so
much for sure and we would obviously
talk about the local teams but obviously
we're doing a Morning Show as well so
you gotta you know see what the internet
is talking about you know what's going
on locally is there something in town
we'd always have music guests and you
know actors all kinds of different they
always say Like Rappers want to be
athletes and athletes want to be rappers
well yeah I mean there's a lot of
crossover in the culture especially in
Miami yeah I mean
I mean where it's there's just a lot of
crossover with culture and sports right
and um it's it's really throughout all
of society though it's not even really
it's just with music Sports is such a
big part of our existence and I think we
really got a whole acknowledgment of
that when we lost sports during the
pandemic I was gambling on South Korean
baseball yeah it was bad who wasn't we
needed something live on TV oh it really
for me it will always make me appreciate
just being able to turn a game on during
the regular season that we might be like
oh it doesn't really matter just having
that sense of normalcy taken away from
you yeah was really jarring so but
sports are just a big part of our Lives
what was it like for you because you
guys were still doing TV right yeah so
that I mean because there's like down
times in the sports calendar where
there's I want to say there's like a
patch that we're about to approach we
are very close to over a few weeks NBA
ends and then all you got is baseball
yeah which I'm not the hugest baseball
fan I don't know where you are on
baseball but I'm not very passionate
about baseball but it's like the dark
times it's like waiting for NFL hope
like okay what kind of nerdy [__] is
going on in the NFL that we could hear
about but
um I can only imagine during the
pandemic there's like nothing like I
would be listening to like Bill Simmons
and [__] and they would just be talking
about uh the Michael Jordan documentary
yeah it saved us so Colin and I joke
about it all the time because we didn't
really take any time off
and we did our Regular Show which is
five days a week three hours a day
every day during the pandemics no live
sports yeah so luckily
the timing of the shutdown for our show
matched up with the end of the NFL
season so the NFL season had gotten in
we got through the Super Bowl right and
it was Matt it was you know NFL off
season so even though the NBA shut down
we still had a lot of content going on
with NFL offseason because the NFL just
moves forward with the idea that like
we're gonna get through this and play
the the I think in that off season
DeAndre Hopkins got traded to my
Cardinals for scrapped Tom Brady moved
Tom Brady there was a lot of Aaron
Rodgers stuff uh there was a bunch of
Cam Newton news so we just kind of I
mean we repeated a lot of topics but we
once we got to the dock that's really
when we were like we need something to
talk about let's talk about this Netflix
series right like it's like it's like
it's live we also watched it like that
like everyone was so Dying For Sports
content that we really and there were
some reveals in it for sure but for them
we were watching it like oh my God
what's gonna happen
when we really watched it like it was
live but it was a great experience in
that sense like there were some things
that really kind of all brought us
together as sports fans and that
documentary I mean I'd say this it gave
us content so